there was about a 280 290 pound dude
running around shirtless doing this to
people
and i'm watching him and i'm like
all right
i really hope he doesn't come over here
you know like
so he comes over and his belly's all
sweaty so there's like tracers flying
off his stomach
and his whole stomach's moving all at
once and i'm like i'm never looking away
i knew i was gonna get [ __ ] trapped
in that thing right
and then he said something to me that i
promise you
has never been uttered before in the
history of human beings
he shakes his belly at me and he looks
at me and he goes hey
i go what's up he goes
how many knuckles deep do you think he
can go on my belly button i go what
he goes how many knuckles deep i go none
none knuckles deep dude zero knuckles
deep and he goes why not i was like wow
why would i and he goes everybody's
doing it and i go who the [ __ ] is doing
that
and he goes to everybody
now look guys i'm shrooming
you know what i mean and i don't want to
be the only guy who doesn't figure [ __ ]
this dude's belly button you know what i
mean
i don't want to be debbie downer you
know what i'm here i want to be part of
the group
so i go to him i go uh
oh what finger should i use
[Music]
and he goes
he goes
i'd use the index i go okay
guys wait it gets so much worse
so
i go to lube up my finger right
and he goes nah you won't need lube and
i was like
oh that's good news for me
and it just [ __ ]
with room to spare right
and i look at him i go we got room to
spare big fella and he goes okay and i
go to pull my finger out and you know
when you put your finger in one of those
chinese finger locks
and for whatever reason when you try to
pull it out it clamps down on it
i couldn't get my finger out of his
[ __ ] belly button i went full palm on
this dude's stomach like
because there's no way i'm going out
like that right i'm like
and it just popped out right as soon as
it pops out he looks at me and he goes
we finally found somebody to do it
[Applause]
i said i thought everybody was doing
that he goes who would do that i go now
[Applause]
now
let's get into a little truth time you
ready for a little truth time
truth truth time as a man as a man as a
man i had to fight every fiber in my
body not to smell that finger one
[ __ ] time
don't yuck me you hypocritical
[ __ ] you graze your nuts the
first thing you do is smell them you got
a unicorn on your finger you're never
going to smell that [ __ ] again
now listen i did it i did it
i didn't i didn't i did not do it i did
not do it
i did it and then i gave my brother a
dirty sanchez and i was like hey dude
what does that smell like he walked
around the whole day like this hey
what
what was it
[Music]
because that's the type of [ __ ]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]